[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday April 18th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
last June Apple accomplished something
pretty big for the first time it
accounted for more than half of the
smartphone market in the US according to
Counterpoint research as of December
iPhones represented 52.5 percent of
smartphones being used here and one
Counterpoint analyst said he expects
that figure to keep creeping up so how
did Apple come to dominate the market
there are a few reasons but one big one
doesn't have anything to do with new
iPhone models with me to sort through
this is wsjtech columnist Christopher
Mims hey Christopher always great to
have you with us always a pleasure to be
here Christopher in your latest column
you wrote that Apple's dominance isn't
just because it's viewed as cooler than
some other brands so what is it down to
it's down to a lot of factors and one of
course is the dreaded green bubbles and
green bubbles are what outgoing texts
from an iPhone to an Android phone
appear as and when an Android phone is
added to a group iMessage chat it turns
everybody's messages green and it makes
videos tiny and unviewable it's a lot of
undesirable outcomes so there's this
network effect where
there's a lot of peer pressure
especially among young people for
everyone to be on an iPhone
however there's another big phenomenon
going on which is somewhat under the
radar because it's less exciting which
is that the market for used and
refurbished phones has absolutely
exploded and it's growing 14 per year it
represents you know one in eight phones
purchased in the US already
and a lot of those devices are Apple
devices because iPhones last a lot
longer part of this is build quality but
a big part of it is just that Apple
supports old phones with new operating
system updates
for much longer than any other handset
maker up to six years currently
is there an area where we've seen this
in action where we just see all iPhones
being used more and more definitely
pass a lot of old iPhones being shipped
to
developing markets but increasingly
they're getting recirculated inside of
wealthier countries so they are being
handed to young people they're being
handed to the budget conscious the value
conscious in my own family when it was
time to give my
newly christened teens devices you know
I just went on back market and found
last generation iPhone se's which were
less than 200. part of this also is that
phones just aren't changing as much
generation and generation so when I gave
them those devices they did everything
that they needed them to do and for a
fraction of the price of a new phone do
rival companies like say Samsung do
something similar Samsung has gotten
wise to Apple's playbook in terms of
making its phones last longer and just
this past month announced that they are
going to support
their Android phones for four years
after their release which is still of
course less than the six years that
Apple supports their devices
and that's only what their newest phones
Samsung also is exceptional most Android
phone makers do not support their phones
for that long
what does this mean for Apple's sales
though I mean if everybody's just
reusing their old phones or buying
cheaper versions of reused phones is
that hitting Apple's bottom line at all
so far Apple has managed to grow its
proportion of the premium phone market
which is anything above six hundred
dollars
fast enough to make it so that these
older devices aren't impacting its sales
so it just keeps grabbing more and more
of the expensive phone market so apple
is winning at both ends of this spectrum
selling more premium devices than ever
and capturing more of the low end
through used devices than ever does it
help Apple at all to have sort of these
low end reused devices on the market
apart from people being seen using them
apart from maybe it makes people think
they're cooler does Apple as a company
get anything from it Apple's done this
amazing job of creating this totally new
stream of Revenue which they can extract
from any iPhone whether it's used or new
and they call this their services
Revenue so that's the percentage take
that they get on every app that's sold
through their app store it's also things
like Apple TV plus Apple music iCloud
this now represents about 20 percent of
Apple's revenue and an even larger
portion of Apple's profits because
services are software so they're highly
profitable Christopher the thing is at
the end of the day apple is a smartphone
maker it does want to sell new versions
of its phones and we've seen across the
market that premium models are doing
better so might it lean on the premium
higher end models to attract new
customers if it has this robust resale
Market already I think absolutely I mean
the funny thing is that these trade-in
programs I think help people
buy more expensive iPhones right because
they're not just paying full Freight
even if they're going with a carrier
right they're getting to sometimes three
four hundred dollars on these trade-ins
and every year Apple's what's called
average selling price just keeps going
up because they just keep adding more
you know honorifics to their phone so
first we have the pro now it's the 14
pro Max I wouldn't be surprised if there
was like a 14 pro Max and God knows what
they'll add to a plus or something and
they'll just make some they'll be an
extra camera bump or some screen thing
or whatever because people have this
incredible appetite for the highest end
devices and we've been talking mostly
about the US market is this the case
globally for Apple
it's been really interesting to see that
Apple has made this Playbook work in a
lot of other countries in South Korea
for example the home of Samsung a
majority of consumers under age 29
actually have Apple devices which I find
incredible you're seeing this play out
in Japan somewhat in Europe maybe less
so but in all of these places where
people have enough money they're opting
for the premium devices they're buying
the used devices and Apple's share of
the installed base just keeps creeping
up alright that's our Tech columnist
Christopher Mims thanks again for
joining us thanks for having me Zoe and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
for more Tech stories head over to our
website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]